so wenige minuten noch dann wird das
bundesverfassungsgericht seine
entscheidung verkünden eine entscheidung
die ja übrigens beruht auf der
mündlichen verhandlung von drei tagen
letztes jahr im märz eine mündliche
verhandlung die chefs verliebt habe und
mein kollege kalt werden aber auch
damals mit uns hier 25 jahren leitete er
die redaktion recht das gewicht der ard
im blick auf die juristerei
herr müller sie haben die mögliche
andere miterlebt ich fand eine
überraschende schafe in der befragung
durch die richter sowohl die
innenminister wurden ins kreuzverhör
kann man das versagen genommen als auch
die npd
ja das kann man in der tat sagen und das
ist ja etwas was das verfassungsrecht
aus meiner sicht in der langzeit wo ich
hier journalistisch gearbeitet habe
auszeichnet es kann hier keine
politische debatte geführt werden
sondern hier ich das mal salopp
formulieren muss butter bei die fische
gegeben wenn das heißt also die richter
prüfen verfassungsrechtlich was ist an
der sache dran und das hat sich auch in
einem geplänkel gezeigt als die
ehemalige parlamentspräsident
landtagspräsidentin bretschneider sagte
wie sie also die npd demo zur ordnung
rufe musste beleidigung und drohungen da
waren und da wollte natürlich der anwalt
der npd dagegen gehen und hat voßkuhl
der präsident des gerichts und des
senates wir sind hier nicht im
plenarsaal sondern ihr sind hier beim
richtet hat das strikt unterbunden und
dennis kauf in der tat schafe aufwand
steuerlich die npd bestritten hat dass
sie rassistisch sei dass sie gegen die
verfassung sei gleichwohl kann doch
deutlich zum ausdruck ihrer gesinnung
die sie auf ihrem programm hat dass sie
zwischen staatsbürgerschaft und
ethnischen deutschen unterscheidet also
ähnlich für deutsche ist nur der deine
mutter deutschen taten deutschen vater
also von daher mein ich müsste man die
npd eigentlich verbieten aber auch so
weit kommt er nach erwähnen was wir auf
jeden fall noch mal machen können ihr
können noch mal eine etappe zeigen was
sich geführt habe vor wenigen minuten
mit dem vorsitzenden der npd und er
macht deutlich dass die partei erwartet
dass es hier kein verbot gibt
wir erwarten das urteil dass wir seit
wochen und monaten prognostizieren
nämlich dass die npd nicht verboten wird
im grunde bin ich so kommt und darauf
deutet der viele filme dann ist hier das
aus ihrer sicht ein erfolg natürlich
eine partei möchte nicht verboten seien
aber der erfolg begründet sich in dieser
weise auf ihrer politischen
erfolglosigkeit denn je
das gericht wird er vermutlich wenn es
sagt kein verbot darauf hinweisen dass
sie weit davon entfernt sind die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung zu gefährden
also zunächst einmal feststellen dass
wir die verfassungsgemäße ordnung gar
nicht beseitigen wollen wir wollen weder
die demokratie noch den rechtsstaat
beseitigen
die npd ist keine partei die gegen die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
ist und deswegen gibt es schlicht und
ergreifend keinen grund die
nationaldemokratische partei deutschland
zu verbieten
gutes gericht offenbar eine andere
meinung für mich war das zuhören wenn
man die mündliche verhandlung verfolgt
sie waren ja dabei ich habe auch gehört
wenn wir davon abgehen wie mir noch
bewertet das hier gesagt worden ist
die npd hat ja im grunde vor dem
verfahren erwartet dafür
verbotsverfahren dazu führen wird dass
man mehr aufmerksamkeit bekommt das ist
eigentlich ein bisschen der partei auch
helfen wird aber in mecklenburg zum
beispiel ist nicht geschehen - sind sie
aus dem landtag aus geflogen
naja wir befinden oder befanden uns ja
in dem verfahren und 2003 als das erste
verfahren gescheitert es war es auch so
dass wir nach dem verfahren einen
entsprechenden zulauf und eine
entsprechende stärkung erfahren haben
es ist natürlich etwas skurril dass die
geballte staatsmacht über jahre hinweg
den wähler suggeriert man könne die npd
nicht wählen weil sie ja sowieso
unmittelbar vor einem verbot stünde
und das hat sich natürlich auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern gezeigt nach dem
heutigen tag wenn die npd definitiv
nicht verboten ist können wir aber das
signal ausgeben das dach vom tisch ist
und dass es jetzt wieder sinn ergibt
nationaldemokraten zu wählen
organisationen wie gegen
rechtsextremismus gegen rechte parteien
auftreten darüber informieren die
befürchten dass die npd nach einem
nicht erfolgten verbot in ihrer
argumentation schärfe aggressiv sein
wird man argumentiert auch das sie
selbst als person als gemäßigt gelten
könnten und dass man aber später
vielleicht noch einen härteren kurs
führen wird ist das wirklich zu erwarten
nein wir haben ein parteiprogramm dort
stehen wird viele drin und die subtile
vertreten wir werden so weitermachen wie
bisher wir wollen eine partei aus der
mitte folge sein und an diesem profil
werden wir weiter arbeiten
das waren 40